- How you doin' New Orleans,
you beautiful goddamn city?!
- [Announcer] Be
the first to see
the next big names in standup
on Comedy Central
Stand-Up Presents.
- You guys could probably
tell this by looking at me,
but I have been fired a lot.
(audience laughing)
- Hilary, like she was
supposed to be my bitch,
and I hated her the whole time.
Like, I voted for her but
only 'cause Barack told me to.
- If you're with
somebody passed a year
and they're still
holding you old night,
you are dating a serial killer.
- I am gay as hell.
I'm great at it.
I was sitting there being black,
and I was like you know what,
give me another thing.
- Well, that's great!
- Woo woo woo woo do do.
- What?!
- I'm from Colorado,
so I'm chill as (beeps)
Do I tie a little bandana
around my dog's neck?
Well, I don't know.
Depends on how
chill I'm feeling.
- Another fun fact about me,
is that I am almost always doing
exactly what a Trump supporter
imagines that I'm doing.
It's a lot of fun.
- I can't hang out with
people wearing windbreakers
'cause it sounds like
they're whispering secrets.
(ruffling)
Say it to my face!
- You all ever go down
on a man whose penis
is so small you feel
like you wanna fill
out a W-9 so you get
money at the end of that?
- Loosen your bundles up.
- Look at what I'm working with.
- I'm gonna get a little nasty.
- At the beginning of yoga class
when they ask you to
set your intention.
And I always set my
intention for revenge.
- In the middle of
kissing, she told me that
she wanted me to choke her.
Now, I don't know about you guys
but I have arthritis
in my hands.
- If an old lady in a
nursing home said the N-word
and all her friends are deaf,
did she really say it?
- I tried exercise.
I didn't realize that you
needed to wear a sports bra
and I almost ripped my tits off.
- Skinny girls will take
an Instagram picture
maybe show a little boob,
a little bit of butt,
people are like,
"Oh, what a slut!
"They're such a slut!"
I do it, and they're like,
"Oh."
(audience laughing)
- [Announcer] Comedy
Central Stand-Up Presents
premieres Friday,
September 15th at midnight.
- You go girl!
(upbeat music)